all right for years i've been saying
make a better bagel make me better pizza
why can't we have pizza or burgers or
bagels that help you lose weight this
would be an amazing thing for an
entrepreneur to take on because think
about how much it sucks to be fat well
you don't have to worry about that
because i've thought about it man i was
tipping the scales at over 200 now i'm
down to a schfelt 182.
it's better to be thinner than to be fat
sorry trigger warning it's healthier to
not be obese i know we're not allowed to
talk about this anymore but uh how did i
do it well i just ate less food
and
a lot less carbs
and carbs taste delicious and our bodies
love carbs well i was on the interwebs
and i saw one of my friends had tweeted
about a better bagel
and i was like oh there it is some
entrepreneur
is making a bagel that is uh you know
less bad for you i'm from brooklyn
bagels are part of the four food groups
along with pizza
and cannolis uh
and so i actually ordered these bagels
and they were pretty good so i said to
my
production team
producers get me the founder well the
founder is here uh the name of the
company is better brand and you can find
them at eat better.com
or you can follow them on twitter
eatbetterbrand and
in her first appearance here on this
week in startups amy yang welcome to the
program
thanks so much for having me i'm so um
excited to be here and and what an
amazing you know personal anecdote and
intro and you know exactly why we
created better right to solve that pain
point that i think is so personal to to
so many people across the board
being fat is bad for you we can all
agree on that right
what's bad for your health
well i i mean i i wouldn't necessarily
say that i think you know obesity you
know certainly there are
like numerous negative health
implications associated with that
diabetes pain suffering exactly diabetes
but i think it's more about that mindset
of freedom right and not having to worry
about what you eat and and how that's
going to affect your weight gain or
weight loss and you know kind of reading
that world like you were saying you were
you know imagining and dreamed of for so
many years of you know being able to eat
all the foods that you crave
and not have to worry about weight gain
or negative health consequences
so let's talk about your first uh
product you made a bagel how did you
come to the conclusion that you wanted
to make a bagel um yeah well so you know
i guess kind of taking a step back and
talking about better brand as a whole um
we're really looking to put our steak in
the ground as leading innovators in the
refined carb space
right and and you know a way to think
about that is beyond meat of carbs
right and in itself pretty good framing
well it's interesting also you know
refined carbs industries 10 trillion
dollar industry right and you look at
all the innovation that's happening and
plant-based at around you know 1.4
trillion so it was just this huge open
space that you know i was just
shocked that no one has come in and and
doing this so so you know in putting our
saving ground as leading innovators in
the refined car space what better way to
do that than by taking the most carp
heavy food and reducing it to the carb
equivalent of let's say two banana
slices
so the carbs in a typical bagel
about 50 grams of wow yes and we've
gotten it down to five
okay so uh how do you do that
what is the uh secret sauce yeah i'm
looking here 48 grams in a typical bagel
makes total sense you get it down to
five is it just a matter of putting
protein powder in it are you using some
different type of flour almond flour oh
my god i've seen all these different
concepts uh but what is the secret sauce
going on here
yeah um there's a lot that goes into it
and it's so funny so fast company
recently released an article and the
title is can food tech invent a better
bagel and that's kind of you know what
we did right um and so
you know in terms of like the the how um
oh my gosh so one is proprietary
formulation you know really novel
ingredients that we've sourced we've
worked with we've understood and so for
example if you look at our ingredient
deck the first ingredient is you know
modified wheat starch so what that is is
it's a wheat but it's not um actually
digestible in your gastrointestinal
tract so right so it doesn't provide
that carb content but what it allows for
is that same viscoelasticity of
a typical wheat that gets you that same
chew and that texture and so you know
that's kind of an example of of just the
normal formulation that we've put
together um you know very so this is a
different type of wheat or what what is
it called wheat what modified wheat
starch
so it's you know you take it's you know
non-gmo right and it's just it's
processed in a way to where the fibrous
content of the wheat is retained but
still allows for you know the texture
and it to provide you know the elastic
properties of the wheat you would expect
from a bagel just without the carb
content and then you yeah and then so
you know that applies to so many
ingredients across the board that we
worked with and formulated and then
um you know the second part of that is
our proprietary process in terms of
development and working with a dough so
if you took this dough and you brought
it to
anywhere um no one would know what to do
with it you know if you tried to make it
the same way and so so everything was
kind of custom designed from from
inception to work with this specific
product profile and then third um
i'm not sure how much i'm supposed to
say about this but we really lean into
you know enzyme technology um in the
biological catalyst right that are
extracted from plants but they help us
you know um in and it's
i always think this is so funny because
you smell such a small amount of it that
it's the last thing on your ingredient
deck um obviously completely natural but
without it the product would be
completely different
um so you know it helps us with texture
taste uh you know flavor taste chew
there's so many parts that go into it
but you know that's kind of the how got
it and there's potato starch in it i see
here chicory root fiber extra virgin
olive oil yeast organic brown rice flour
organic white vinegar sea salt and
enzyme so yeah it seems pretty
straightforward very freeze
yeah 375 a bagel when you buy a 12 pack
so four bucks if you buy less
compared to
50 cents a dollar for a typical bagel
when you are trying to grow a startup
fast hiring engineers will slow you down
like nothing else don't i know it so
many companies i invest in are telling
me they can't get their next version out
because they don't have a great engineer
well lemon.io will find you a perfect
candidate in just 48 hours it's a
marketplace of engineers from europe and
they test and interview every developer
to eliminate the risk of a failed
project lemonio is the perfect solution
if you are a technical co-founder and
you need to delegate some of your
important tasks or you have a project
that needs specific technology and you
don't have that skill on your team yet
or you are just growing so fast that you
need to add more developers and get more
done faster they'll match you with a
candidate within 48 hours and if it
doesn't work out they'll replace the
developer right away so here is your cta
the old call to action if you could use
a full-time or even part-time developer
to run your projects faster go to lemon
dot io slash twist once again lemon
l-e-m-o-n dot io slash twist and you'll
receive a 15 discount for the first four
weeks of work with that amazing
developer well done lemon okay check it
out everybody lemon dot io slash twist